i'd like to welcome you
today to our
symposium on neurotechnologies
human applications and we have a great
lineup of speakers today and i think
one thing you'll see is it really spans
across
novel applications of fda approved
implantable devices as well as
investigational devices
our speakers are claudia
angeli who will speak on closed-loop
spinal cord stimulation
philip starr will tell us about in-home
chronic human brain recording
nanthia suthana will speak on ambulatory
human brain and
behavior recording michelle
armantia salas will speak on
visual prosthesis and then we'll hear
from harrison walker
on directional leads and then we'll wrap
up with a
important uh final talk from winston
join
on neuro ethics so with that
we'll turn it over to the first speaker
so i will be talking about overground
walking after a more
complete spinal cord injury this is a
collaboration
that has taken place over about a nine
year period
we know that the spinal cord
and neural control of walking
has the capacity to
[Music]
oscillate independent of super spinal
influence that means that the spinal
cord is smart enough to generate
certain patterns without
necessarily the influence from the brain
it also has the capacity
to organize flexors and extensors for
the lower extremities as it
generates walking the inner limb
coordination the interaction between
specific sensory cues and we know that
motor
output actually improves with specific
practice that means that whatever you
practice
that's the pattern that actually is
going to improve
when we actually put individuals with
motor complete spinal cord injury or
even
more incomplete spinal cord injury on a
treadmill
and we step them with manual assistance
we actually see that there's different
motor patterns that are generated from
very little activity from from the
muscles
to quite a bit of activity and
coordinated activity
throughout the steps we see that this
actually is both
goes from a low level of activity in
some individuals and high level of
activity in others
and this is due to the what we call this
resting level of excitability
of the spinal cord so
from previous research we know that the
spinal cord the spinal super tree
plays a very important role in the
generation
of motor output and it can interpret
very complex information
coming from the periphery sensor
information
the the ground reaction forces
and the spinal cord is actually the
primary controller for motor behavior
with this information we set out to
do uh initially a proof of principle
um study looking at implanting
an electrode a 16-electron ray over the
lumbosacral spinal cord
to see if we can improve this motor
patterns that were generated as a result
of
activity dependent practice
and we
did two different comparisons of
individuals that received locomotor
training
with the the first group receiving 80
sessions of stand training
followed by 80 sessions of locomotor
training and then we
we implanted a second group of
individuals that actually did both
standing
and the locomotive training
simultaneously
they just alternated uh days for
uh that specific practice so you can
actually see
that the two groups were fairly similar
in terms of clinical characteristics
they were similar in age they were
similar in time since injury
and the level of injury we had
individuals that were motor
and sensory complete as well as motor
complete
but sensory incomplete and both groups
had
two uh two of each so the only
difference again was that one group
did 80 sessions of standing first and
then they followed by 80 sessions of
stepping all with stimulation after the
implantation
and then the other group we actually
interleave the
the two training paradigms
when we look at the data we actually
compared how
the two groups did in standing ability
and
the first group you can see that the the
top graph the
the blue bar graph shows the amount of
knee independence that this individuals
could have
throughout a a full training session
and the second group did better than the
first group so those that actually stood
and did local motor training um
together in alternating days did
better in standing than the first group
and then the green
um bars are the amount of
actually hip independence and knee
independence so that's that's all is
standing
fully independent and we were not as
successful
with the first group but certainly the
second group showed that they could
actually stand for almost the the full
training session with
both hips and knee independently so now
we'll show
a couple of videos the first video will
be
one individual the best individual out
of the first group
so if we can play the
will show the individual from group two
so the big difference between those two
individuals that you saw in the videos
is that the first individual from group
one had a
thoracic level 4 injury and the second
individual
was a cervical 5 injury so he had very
little
trunk and hand control
but even so he was able to maintain
independent knees
and when holding on he was able to also
maintain independent hips through
the standing when he was receiving
stimulation
now for this
when we compare walking we actually can
see that
intent plays a big role in individuals
ability to
uh step and if you look at the
the motor output from stepping
in the left hand side you see that the
individual had the intent to step
the right leg while he was receiving
assistance on the left leg
and the motor output is actually
appropriate for
stepping that right leg so there's
coordination on the right
leg muscles but there isn't appropriate
coordination on the left leg muscles
but when the intent changes of his
intent is
specific to the left leg then the
appropriateness of the coordination
actually switches so
the spinal cord is able to to modulate
that
and interpret that information uh coming
from
whatever supraspinal information is
coming through and able to organize the
muscles appropriately for the intent of
the individual so if we can
play the video for the left
slide
play the video for the right
only difference between those two videos
is the intent of the individual to focus
its effort
on the left leg or right leg
um and the simulation was the same
nothing
changed other than his intent so this
means that
the spinal cord has that capacity to to
organize
uh the different uh intent and
information from the periphery now
where we actually were able to uh
be able to get two individuals out of
the second group
was that they were actually able to
walk overground fairly independent
and one of the things that we found was
that these two individuals
reach the ability to stand and step
with the same simulation configurations
which is very uh minimal changes so
there's either some changes in voltages
or some changes in frequency that were
needed for them to be able to
stand for prolonged period periods of
time
when they weren't um necessarily walking
or stepping
so one of the the big things is that
individuals need to manually make these
changes right now and if they're
they're walking or or just having to
to stop and wait for traffic to go by
they their ability to stand with the
with a stepping configuration
is very fatiguing to them so they need
those parameters to be adjusted
for them to be able to stand for
prolonged periods of time but both
individuals actually
reach they converge into one single
configuration with some parameter
changes
so if we play the the video on the top
okay and we'll play the video on the
bottom
so this is the same individual using the
same
simulation configuration same pattern of
stimulation with some minor differences
in um in a stimulation amplitude for
both standing
and stepping so our
objective for this brain initiative
project is to use the information coming
from
the accelerometer inside the
nerve stimulator and use that
um to gather information to see if the
individual is actually moving
or standing still so detect this changes
in position and
through a predictive algorithm be able
to
change uh make changes to the simulation
to optimize for the task so if the
individual
wants to walk or if they want to to
take a break and stand for a defined
period of time
the algorithm will automatically change
those stimulation parameters and
the other aspect of this project is
bladder bladders it's it's a big issue
with individuals with spinal cord injury
they um they do not have the ability
to um to manage
to have a good bladder management
program
and to the integration of
bladder control and and really
monitoring of
blood pressure as we train individuals
for storage as well as voiding
uh integrated into a closed-loop
algorithm
um to change stimulation parameters
uh as well uh during the the uh
the stimulation so our goal
is to pretty much develop technology
that will interact
with the currently available stimulators
and facilitate the
the implementation and integration of
training programs really for the
recovery of locomotion and bladder
function in individuals with acute
spinal cord injury
to promote safe long-term use of the
technology
in the home and community
this is really a group effort between a
number of
investigators as well as all of our
research participants that
uh really put a lot of effort in
in the training coming in the lab every
day
so and the next presenter will be
phil starr
okay i'm going to be talking about
in-home chronic human brain recording in
the motor system
this is going to be in patients with
parkinson's disease who are already
undergoing deep brain stimulation for
their clinical problem of parkinson's
disease
so a lot has been learned in parkinson's
disease from
invasive human brain recording and most
of this has been done
either intraoperatively or
perioperatively from externalized leads
in a hospital setting
so we could learn quite a bit more if we
could do the same invasive recordings
over long periods of time with very high
volumes of recordings
in patients homes during naturalistic
activities and that's what my talk is
about
we used in this protocol a new
neurotechnology device
summit rc plus s it's an investigational
deep brain stimulator and sensing device
that has been available since 2018 but
only for investigational purposes
it is from medtronic but the protocol
was designed by us and the devices were
provided for free by medtronic
so the first slide shows basically what
we did
here we're going to talk about the first
four patients in the study
who are bilaterally implanted with the
summit rc plus s
device and the figure shows the
configuration
patients had a bilateral rc plus s
each attached to a subthalamic nucleus
deep brain stimulator electrode
for the purpose of therapy delivering
therapy and sensing
and the rc plus s was attached to a
motor cortex
electrode just for the purpose of
sensing and these patients can then
transmit
wirelessly by a few feet up to a small
communicator that can then transmit over
distance of about 40 feet
to a small tablet computer that can be
in their homes
we did intensive data streaming for many
hours for the first month
after device implantation but prior to
initiation of stimulation
so as to understand the brain physiology
underlying the fluctuations from
effectively medication off states and
medication on states which i'll be
illustrating in a bit
we then did ongoing sensing at home
after the initiation of standard deep
brain stimulation therapy
in order to understand the effects of
dbs and to test and begin to implement
adaptive or feedback controlled deep
brain stimulation
so this slide illustrates where the
electrodes are
the upper left shows a axial mri
showing the four contact cortical leads
on each side
spanning the central sulcus which is
indicated with an arrow so we have
context over primary motor area as well
as primary sensory area
the subthalamic nucleus the white dots
are the ct artifact
from ctmr fusion showing the leads
located in the subthalamic nucleus
bilaterally
we also show here in the middle just
examples of the
local field potentials two channels from
each sub-climatic nucleus and two
channels
from each motor cortical area
we did want to confirm that we could
obtain
so-called broadband gamma responses from
this device with the motor cortex
electrode
we expect that when movement is
initiated uh broadband activity up to
200 hertz or so
should be detectable from primary motor
cortex if the device can't
detect frequencies up that high so here
on the right of the slide we've just
done a simple
motor test with these patients this is
right after implantation
the dotted line shows the time of
initiation of
of a simple movement so when movement
occurs
in this motor cortex ecog recording
you can see the expected beta band
desynchronization here in blue
and then this very broadband from 50 up
to 200 hertz
of activation as has been shown with
externalized e-cog leads recorded from
externalized devices
so now we can show the same physiology
up to high frequencies
using this completely implanted device
so i'm going to show a video which is
really going to illustrate the kinds of
brain behavior
correlations that we can see with this
device
this video is going to show a patient
not at home but
in the hospital one day after
implantation the remaining data i'll
show after this will all be at home data
recordings
we picked this because we wanted to
capture a dramatic transition in this
patient from
an immobile state where he's uh
bradykinetic and rigid
and the state that he transitions to
after taking his parkinsonian
medications
which is mobile but very dyskinetic and
this is the problem
that these patients have for which we've
implanted deep brain stimulation
so the video is about 30 seconds and
what you're going to see on the left is
the video of the actual patient starting
out immobile and then after a few
seconds he will begin to show
involuntary dyskinetic movements then on
his right
there will be um an upper trace of the
motor cortex electrocardio
corticography trace uh synchronized with
the video
which will show after the transition to
the dyskinetic state the appearance
of about a 70 hertz oscillation in motor
cortex in the spectrogram
that coincides with the onset of
dyskinesia
the lower trace is going to be the
subthalamic nucleus local field
potential
which at the beginning when he's
immobile will show a very strong
oscillation in the beta band about 20
hertz and that will suddenly
decrease when he makes the transition on
the video from
the immobile state to the disc kinetic
state
okay so um all the rest of the slides
are going to be
data from these patients at home and
using this device is the first time that
we've been able to record continuous or
near
continuous neural signals from multiple
channels in the home environment for
many hours we don't have a neurologist
in at home in the room to tell what
motor state this patient is in so we
have to have some way of telling that
this patient
is in one of those off states where
they're immobile and rigid or the on
state where they're moving around
but may have the complication of
levodopa induced dyskinesias
so to do this home monitoring patients
used a wearable this is the pkg watch
from global kinetics
and this gives an output as illustrated
in the lower left of the slide
gives an output of a score for
bradykinesia
and a score for dyskinesia you can show
that these occur
essentially at opposite times when the
patient is bradykinetic or slow
and they tend to be dyskinetic that is
they're mobile and have
excess involuntary movements so we
collected
about 80 hours of home recordings in
this patient in the time
after implantation before stimulator
activation
and we plotted power spectra as shown on
the right for
10 minute segments of data this case is
the average
10-minute segment for those data in one
of these two conditions
the blue line shows all of the
recordings over many hours
when the watch said that the patient was
immobile
and this shows a prominent peak in the
power spectrum
in the beta range the scale didn't make
it on here but this is about a
20 hertz oscillation then
in all of the hours of recordings where
the
wearable showed that the patient was
mobile
the power spectrum the sub of the
subthalamic nucleus field potential does
this
it has a drop out of that 20 hertz beta
oscillation
although this is the cortical electro
corticography signal recorded
at the same time on these uh 80 hours or
so recordings
and whenever the patient is mobile and
dyskinetic as shown in the green line
this um about 80 hertz oscillation
appears and the
[Music]
beta band activity does decrease over
motor cortex
so what this slide illustrates is it
shows that what
we observed on the previous video that
30 second recording can be recapitulated
over many hours of recording
as segregated by a wearable monitor with
patients taking their normal schedule of
parkinsonian medications
so one important question in the field
of decoding motor state and parkinson's
and this comes up in many other brain
disorders is
how many brain sites do you need to be
able to understand
the relevant brain states for a
particular disorder
so in our protocol we deliberately
implanted two different areas of the
motor system subthalamic nucleus and
motor cortex
and we ask the question these four
patients how good are we at decoding
the effectively on versus off states
that is mobile versus immobile states in
these four patients
on the left here just shows the total
number of hours that we
recorded in these patients so over these
four patients we showed the
uh hours recorded during awake times and
asleep times just in that first month
before starting therapeutic stimulation
we collected over 1100 hours of eight
channel recordings
then we asked the question if we want to
how accurate are we
at decoding the patients as
immobile or mobile based on receiver
operator curve analysis
looking at the area under the curve so
if you just look at
single side activity such as the stn
beta activity or motor cortex gamma
activity
you ten you can do pretty well but you
get around a 0.7 to 0.8
area under the curve over these
different patients and different
channels of recording
but if you actually combine both targets
and that's shown
over here on the right of this graph you
get an area under the curve which is
closer to 0.9 so you get much better
decoding of motor state
when you do multi-site recording in the
motor system
so what i talked about before is the
form of so-called supervised learning
that is
we recorded many hours of data at home
and then used a wearable monitor
to separate those data by immobile
versus mobile that's labor intensive of
course to analyze
all the wearable recordings ideally for
this kind of technology
you would like to be able to segregate
brain states
in an unsupervised manner simply by
using a mathematical algorithm
to separate uh states and see if they
correspond to a physiological
physiological state and that doesn't
involve nearly as much analysis
so here we did this using a clustering
algorithm
adapted from a paper in science
published in 2014
and what we what we show here are
many superimposed power spectra of
10-minute
segments of data so each power spectrum
is for a 10-minute segment of data from
the 80 hours of recording
and then we allow the clustering
algorithm to work on these power
spectrum
and see what it decided uh were the
different clusters
and in fact this clustering algorithm
did for the sub thalamic recordings
uh determined that there were really two
clusters of power spectra in purple here
and in yellow
the purple one has a big peak in the
beta range about 20 hertz
the yellow does not and these clearly
correspond to those
immobile versus mobile uh segments as we
did in the supervised learning in the
prior work
likewise in the cortex the unsupervised
clustering algorithm
clustered into two different clusters
with this strong 80 hertz oscillation
in one of those clusters and that
clearly corresponds to the mobile but
dyskinetic state
we also asked what happens now with
therapeutic deep brain stimulation what
does it do to these oscillatory markers
of parkinsonian state we know that
chronic therapeutic dbs is quite
effective for
improving patients mobility and reducing
bradykinesia and rigidity
what happens to this subthalamic beta
activity thought to be a biomarker of
this parkinsonian a
kinesia so here we have violin plots
for the beta activity from two different
patients
one here on the left and one on the
right so in this patient which is the
first in the protocol
you can see this hourglass configuration
of the distribution of beta activity
corresponding to those hours when he was
often immobile with the higher beta
or on and more mobile and that's the
lower beta activity
then we then recorded about 40 hours of
activity at home
during dbs again with their normal
medication schedule
patient moving around their home as
needed or sometimes going outside the
home with the recording device
and the distribution of beta activity
was collapsed from this bimodal
distribution
into this more physiological unimodal
distributions
in both cases so in this technology we
can now start to study
over long periods what are the effects
of acute and chronic deep brain
stimulation
on these biomarkers of a brain state
finally we've started to use our
understanding of
brain state from home implement adaptive
deep brain stimulation
that is having the stimulation instead
of being constantly on
as in standard therapeutic stimulation
we wanted to be smart
and adjust the amplitude of stimulation
according to changing brain needs
so after starting therapeutic
stimulation these patients are still
requiring
some of their levodopa medications and
they need more medication
when the medic need more stimulation
when the medication wears off and less
stimulation
when the medication is effectively
working this shows the beta activity
and stimulation current on the bottom in
one of our patients
over about eight hours during about
three medication
cycles here with the blue this is the
input signal to the classifier
and the red lines are the two thresholds
of beta activity at which stimulation
changes are triggered
so here in the morning he's actually
taken his medications his beta activity
is relatively low and his stimulator
is actually set quite low in his case
zero he got very dyskinetic if he had
this
stimulation on during his medication on
stage
then as his medicine wears off the
biomarker for motor state
beta activity in the stn in this case
goes up crosses the threshold
and triggers this uh increase in
stimulation current
to about 1.3 milliamps and likewise this
occurred reliably over three cycles of
medications
and this patient felt a lot better on
his on the
closed loop stimulation than on the open
loop stimulation where he would have had
to constantly change himself stimulation
levels
to account for those those medication
changes
so this work uses an interface the
summit rc plus
s which is very flexible but it's also
very complex
we get the flexibility from programming
the devices functions ourselves
in the application programming interface
of the device which is a new technique
for most investigators so we worked with
three other
academic sites including gregorill's
site at mayo clinic
in the so-called open mind consortium
which is a group that is sharing
technology related to
these new types of neural interfaces and
there will be a workshop on this on june
3rd
you can contact us if you would like to
participate in the workshop and haven't
already heard about it
this is the large team that contributed
to these and this work was funded mainly
by
the brain initiative uh 3 grant so just
to summarize i've talked about a new
investigational implantable device the
rc plus s for medtronic that allows
continuous wireless invasive brain
recording at home
i've illustrated it in parkinson's
disease but this is actually a very
flexible
platform that can and is being used in a
wide range of disorders including
pain epilepsy and psychiatric disorders
we've shown that behavioral states of
high clinical relevance in parkinson's
such as the immobile versus mobile and
kinetic states can be resolved with
brain recordings at both basal ganglia
and motor cortex sites
we've also shown that unsupervised
machine learning can identify these
relevant neural signatures and that
could obviously be applied to other
brain conditions as well
and we've illustrated the use of
adaptive deep brain stimulation now with
a fully embedded device
thank you our next speaker is uh
nam pia suthana who is assistant
professor at
ucla who will be talking about brain
recording in
other systems all right hi everyone i'm
going to talk today about to mobile deep
brain recordings and stimulation
and another system the neuropathy
responsive nerve simulator and how it
can
help neuroscientists scientific studies
of naturalistic behaviors in humans
so as a neuroscientist the traditional
measures of
neural activity in humans suffer from
the
inability of participants to move so
there are movement artifacts
that restrict them to stay still this is
you know techniques like fmri and others
and they some of them also record and
stimulate from superficial areas and the
tasks that are used are also
on computer screens two-dimensional and
so
low in ecological validity so with the
development of the responsive
neurostimulator and
other chronically implanted systems we
are able to record
intracranial eg as you can see above
here in an example
raw trace from a patient that has
a system implanted in the hippocampus
and in these patients we can record
intracranial eg as well as various other
behavioral measures such as motion
via full body motion capture system
which i will show you here in this video
so if you could play
this video here and
in the video you can see a patient
walking around
as a motion as their movements are being
captured with some millimeter precision
they can also wear a scalp eeg cap and
other wearable
technologies such as virtual reality
headsets augmented reality headsets for
stimulating more
naturalistic experiences with higher
ecological validity
so this is the full platform that we've
developed which is a series of
accessories that allow us
to in real time view the intracranial eg
data
as well as insert markers to synchronize
it with
wearable data streams and also trigger
on demand
the simulator for various experiments so
it involves various accessories that are
carried in a backpack that weighs about
nine pounds but there are also lighter
weight versions depending on the
participant
uh that are a little bit less accurate
in terms of synchronization so about a
half a second
versus milliseconds you can also use
this platform to do
stationary computer-based tasks
traditional
neuroscience studies to compare those as
well
the participants can also wear various
wearables
that can record physiological
measurements such as skin conductance
rate respiration heart rate
pupilometry eye blink responses
and they can do so either indoors in la
in the laboratory setting or outdoors in
natural settings
in their home and this is what it looks
like you know the full wear up
and the full setup and the lightweight
version as well
and again the headsets of your choice
the virtual reality and augmented
reality headsets of your choice
or just eye tracking headsets that are
coming out these days that are quite
effective so what can you do with this
platform
you can do various neuroscientific
investigations
my own lab studies episodic memory and
spatial navigation
through a u1 funded project but we can
also do
uh studies that are relevant for
neurologic and psychiatric
disorders whether it's developing new
treatments and testing those treatments
so we have a collaboration with
john phillipe langevin who actually has
a poster here at the brain initiative on
the ch3 project
for using the rns to treat ptsd
in combat veterans and we also have
another one collaboration with stanford
casey halpern looking at loss of
controlled eating
so this platform in my own lab we are
using to
understand the electrophysiological
features of
memory and spatial navigation we have
another video here if you could play
this one
you can see a participant navigating a
virtual
reality environment and they can learn
various locations that we can measure
their memory for
via a handheld joystick that they press
a button when they remember where they
are
and then we've done this in five
participants so far we see a learning
rate that is
increasing over repetitions of the
experiment
and then we can see what's happening in
their brain we find the presence of
theta oscillations these high frequency
oscillations that are implicated in
memory and navigation
and they seem to be more prevalent when
walking faster versus walking slower
and we also see these theta oscillations
carry information about where the
individuals are in space as well as the
heading direction
with respect to the orientation of the
room and this is analogous to this
you know grid cells that are recorded in
these same areas
and torrential cortex that are thought
to be important for spatial navigation
we've done this in four participants so
far where we see theta
activities higher during orientations
that are aligned with the
grid that is an individual participant
and for more information you can look at
the the article that's online
we've also found that the theta
oscillations carry information about
whether you are closer to a wall
boundary or
are farther away from that boundary in
that the
power increases closer to boundaries
potentially reflective of boundary
related mechanisms that have been found
in single cells and rodents
and gamma activity also seems to
differentiate
these two positions in a space
interestingly we found that this
boundary modulation which was present
very strongly in all participants tested
is further modulated by their causative
state so if a participant is focused
on a task that requires a higher memory
demand you see that
differentiation between theta in the
boundaries versus the inner
but you don't see it when they're just
following cues that are located on the
wall
lastly we've used this platform to look
at the neurophysiological mechanisms of
hypervigilance and emotional memory to
motivate the uh-3 for
treatment study for ptsd uh we record
physiological measurements while
participants have
amygdala and hippocampus and prefrontal
and or recordings uh to look at
activity during the presentation of
images that carry a valence either
positive or negative valence so this is
the iaps
database for effects and we see that
in participants who have core
morbidities such as ptsd
or generalized anxiety from the veterans
uh we're collaborating with the va
in los angeles we see an increased theta
activity
about a half a second after the onset of
the stimulus
that's around six hertz in the right
baselateral amygdala we don't see this
in hippocampus or other
areas so it's specific to this area here
and we're exploring whether there's a
difference between
individuals who have anxiety disorders
versus those that do not
and we've tested so far five
participants and there's a
trend in the effect that this theta
activity is increasing and all of them
during negatively v
images that have negative valence
compared to positive
so that finding here is going to help
motivate the clinical trial
to treat ptsd patients based on this
biomarker this theta oscillation and the
right amygdala
so to summarize this platform so far has
enabled studies to look at theta
oscillations during memory and spatial
navigation
specifically walking behavior and how it
uh how in humans for the first time
we see that it carries information about
actual position in space
not just virtual space in a computer
task and that this positional modulation
whether it's boundary related or grid
related
is stronger after memory is formed or in
periods where high memory demand
is relevant uh and then we see low
frequency theta oscillations in the base
lateral mingle in the right hemisphere
in a small subset of patients after they
view negative stimuli compared to
positive stimuli so we're translating
that last binding into this clinical
trial
this is just showing one patient's
clinical scores for ptsd over for
almost four years with a continuous
stimulator
which will now move into a
theta-triggered responsive stimulator
with the use of the rns
and there's a poster here at the brain
initiative if you're interested in
finding out more uh from p.i
john p langevin so all together to
summarize this is a novel research
platform for cognitive and
clinical neuroscience studies you can
with this platform
uh enable wireless stimulation and
recording that's programmable
and in real time in deep brain regions
of freely moving behaviors
in patients in participants who have the
implanted rns
and then when combined with wearables
like vr and ar headsets
motion capture physiological
measurements you have an
opportunity to investigate naturalistic
human behaviors
under experimental control and answer
neuroscientific questions here and also
develop
new therapies and test those therapies
in more realistic environments before
the patients go out into their home
ethical considerations for this system
include
when you do research studies potentially
withholding the responsive
neurostimulation treatment
of course this is up to the decision of
the participant
and actually can be it can be prevented
if you optimize recruitment
which is what we do to include
participants that have very low
seizure activity so that there aren't
that many detections during the research
uh the research studies utilize a very
low amount of battery but this is a
issue of course that needs to be taken
under consideration so what we do is
limit research time per participant
there are over 2 000
participants in the us right now with
the neural pace rns so there are plenty
of participants
to sort of recruit for research rather
than
doing all the studies in one participant
and thereby reducing their battery which
that they have to
be replaced earlier and then of course
you want to ensure
security of any kind of connection of
wireless connection between
any additional accessories that allow
the platform to view the data in real
time
and so we have various ways of doing
this as well
so with that i'd like to thank the lab
members postdocs
and graduate students and all of the
collaborators and funding
that supports this work thank you and uh
i'll introduce the next speaker which um
is next speaker is michelle armentesalis
to speak okay hi everyone uh i'll be
talking about the year one results for
the orion visual cortical prosthesis
the early feasibility study so this is a
clinical trial sponsor by second side
in collaboration with ucla baylor
college of medicine and the alfred mann
foundation
just as a little bit of a background so
i've been one of the
researchers that had the pleasure to
work with all of this clinical trial
subjects
and collaborated with the researchers at
ucla
and baylor to plan and execute a lot of
our research sessions
but also be able to program and fit the
system so the subjects can take it and
use it at home
and this has been partially funded by
the brain initiative
apart from the the second side so
just a brief overview on the orion
system so this
is a visual cortical prosthesis that was
designed to directly stimulate
the cortical uh the visual cortex
bypassing
the eye and the optic apparatus to
elicit some type of artificial vision in
completely blind subjects so it has
two main categories of components so the
first uh
the first ones are the implanted
components and this is uh
has a subdural electrode array which is
69 penetrated
channels which are placed uh
inter-hemispherically
on the occipital cortex of the of the
subjects
this connects through a cable to an
electronic package and an implant coil
which are
fully implant implanted so this just lay
flush on the skull
and communicate wirelessly to the
external components which are
which are the one that the users wear so
these components
are a pair of sunglasses that have a
video camera that communicates to a
video processing unit which is the one
that would actually
translate the video images to
stimulation parameters that are sent to
the implant via
a external coil that sends it through an
rf link so this sense both the data
and the power so there are no actual
implanted batteries that need to be
replaced in the system so
the early feasibility study is an open
label single
uh single arm five year study with six
subjects at two different centers as i
previously mentioned in ucla
and waylo college of medicine and the
primary
outcome for this study is the the safety
evaluation
measured through through the reported
adverse event
our secondary outcome measure is to to
test the functionality of the device so
what's our ability to produce phosphines
that is
visual percepts in these blind subjects
test the device longevity and assess the
benefits in terms of the functional
vision that we're able to deliver uh
as well as the the impact and the
quality of life that it may have
for for the subjects
an overview of uh the status and the
subjects that we have so we have a total
of six subjects which we were able to
recruit and implant within the first
year of the study
so four are at ucla and two uh taylor
the average age at the time of implant
was 40 years
and the average duration so as of
earlier this month
was around 24 months so all of the
subjects currently have a functional
system
and they've all taken it home and are
able to to use it according to what the
the principal investigator indicated for
for each patient
for our primary outcome we have had a
total of eight adverse events
across three of our six subjects so we
had one serious adverse event for one
subject
and seven non-serious either divisive
procedure related across the
the three subjects we had had no
unanticipated adverse event
and just to put this in a little bit of
contrast with the
with our pre the previous device that is
a retinal implant
uh from second side so this is the argus
2 visibility study
at 12 months in the first five subject
they had actually reported a total of 25
adverse event two series and it was
across four
of the five subjects so the outlook so
far in the
other 12 months with orion is looking
actually a little bit uh
better than than what we had experienced
with the argus
ii and we obviously continued to monitor
monitor all the adverse events
and and process it with the with the
sides
for our secondary outcomes we
we test the the functional vision in a
few different ways so the first set of
tests are trying to be a little bit more
objective and controlling what the
subjects
report on that what they're able to see
when they're using the device with the
camera
and the the second kind of batch of
chess is trying to get a little bit more
on the subjective side so for the first
set of tasks
we have the first one is one called
square localization
where the subjects are are asked to
localize a single white square on a
black background on a touch screen so we
control
the the input that we're obviously
giving it through the camera because we
we set them in a very black room
and they and they just scan around and
they should localize where they see the
square and when they find it and we
measure the error
looking at the the distance between
where they point
and where the square actually was shown
on the touchscreen
and we do all this test with the system
on and the system off so
if any of the subjects may have even
though most of our subjects have no
light perception
some may have some bare light perception
in the opposite
eye so we allow them to use maybe
whatever they had still left
so for all of our subjects we observe
that they
the majority perform better with the
system on than the system off which is
what we
we would want and we would expect except
for subject three that
actually perform worse with the system
on and the system off
and this was due to the the nature of
where the percepts are localized in the
visual field of this subject
and i could talk a little bit more about
it if you have questions
uh but uh that we observed that actually
the
the spread of the response so like the
randomness is actually
less when the system is on than off for
the subject even though the
overall average errors error is larger
the second task tries to look a little
bit more into like the next step so how
the subjects are
able to to use the spatial information
of the phosphines that they see
from that that we are able to elicit
with the device
so the test is called direction of
motion and here we present a single
white bar again
that's that sweeps across the black
touchscreen
and we asked the subjects to to report
the direction where they saw the bar
moving so they keep their eyes and their
on their head fixated so they're not
allowed to scan
and the bar can move any of 360 degrees
so it's a little bit of a hard task and
given the the field of view that we have
available with the with the implant but
the subjects perform reasonably well so
far with it so we test again with the
system on and the system off
and we observe that all of the subjects
have been able to perform significantly
better
when they're using the system
the third task is gradient visual acuity
so
this is a test that allows us to measure
uh
ultra low vision acuity so it reports
it gives a report between 2.9 and 1.6
log mark
and it it shows a series of gradients
and four different
orientations so either vertical
horizontal
uh or either of the diagonals so here on
the right we see
one of just kind of an example with one
of the subjects uh
performing the task and the gradients
are shown for only five seconds so they
can do very short small scanning
but it would give us an idea of how well
they can process
this this information and and maybe how
it can later
be used to to maybe advance towards uh
towards formation
so we test this with the system on and
the system off
and three out of our six subjects have
been able to score with the system
on and none of them had been able to
score with the system off
the next set of tasks it actually looks
a little bit more it tries to
to probe a little bit more the
subjectiveness of the
of the vision so how well can they can
they actually use it in the real world
and how much
is it useful for them if it's something
that would require like a lot of
training or
even when they have the training if
they're able to use it in their
activities of daily
life so for this one we have the flora
which assess
which kind of take advantage of using
train observers to assess whether the
system or not is actually
having a positive or negative or just a
neutral impact on the subject's life so
they perform a battery of different
activities of daily living and as i
mentioned a train of server
evaluates how well and or how can they
perform this different task
so it gives a final rating on the
benefit that the system has on the
subject
and we've seen and we get the report at
the 12 months that the majority of the
subjects so 5 out of 6 had had either a
positive or a mild positive
impact by by using the system
again just as a brief comparison of
summary
we we've seen that the the system has
been able to have
uh an improvement in the functional
vision and the
and and their ability to to perform
everyday tasks
when the the subjects are used in the
system and in comparison to what we had
observed with argus 2
at the 12 months we see that we have
either very comparable
or even better for some of the tasks for
example in direction of motion
and slightly better with the floral
record that what we had observed yeah
with arcus 2 even though we have a very
limited amount of subjects right now
with this study since it is an early
visibility study
lastly what we also like to to collect
is to look at how
the real world use so what what happens
when the subject just have the device at
home when they're working with rehab
specialties that go to their house and
and train them to be able to use the
device
and what expectations they have to keep
on using the the device in the future
so we have we sent a questionnaire just
asking about their expectations
and their experience so far with with
the device
and hear back from the from the rehab
personnel of
what they've been able to do and what
they've been able to work with the
subjects and kind of like the
the different tasks that they've been
able to to perform and
we we hear back and and we've observed
that the subjects are able to use the
orion system
in everyday activities even for very
simple things that we
would consider simple but for them it's
a huge achievement
and right now they expect to to keep
improving not only to have
to improve the vision that we're able to
offer with the system but also to keep
on
improving on the tasks that they are
able to do
and just in the in the following video
we're going to show an example one of
the subjects
uh and this is uh was given by the
research team at houston
so here we we see the subject able to
use the the system
uh navigating the hallway uh
corridor of the hospital being able to
find corridors to find windows in the
corridors using
using different like the light and dark
cues and being able to navigate by
himself without the assistant of a cane
okay okay and uh
thanks a lot for for your attention i
i'm happy to take any questions
and up next we're going to have dr
harrison walker he's an associate
professor of neurology and the medical
director for brain stimulation at the
university of alabama
in birmingham
my talk is entitled changes in
therapeutic window as a result
of directional brain stimulation
we're grateful to our sources of funding
including a uh-3 grant
from the nih brain initiative
directional brain stimulation is among
a few new device technologies that are
available
in neuromodulation and i think that uh
directional leads are a unique window
into the pathophysiology in human brain
circuits
directional and close-up stimulation
both show promise but they're
they're actually largely unproven and
greatly increase
uh the complexity of dbs therapy because
of their
their great flexibility the
picture on the right shows a directional
brain stimulation lead
and the red blob around the lead is
a computational model
showing steering of current away from us
into the screen
uh by the uh directional
orientation of the contacts on the lead
so this lead is made by boston
scientific who's our industry
collaborator and it's in the so-called
one three three one design
so there are traditional circular leads
at the
extremes and the two middle rows of
contacts
are virtual rings with uh with
directional dbs contacts
this is particularly important in the
subthalamic nucleus and some of the
local anatomy
is is highlighted below the picture
uh the sdn is located very near
eloquent structures that can cause uh
benefits and and side effects as well
and so
um we'll discuss in this talk our
characterization of how directional vbs
affects side effect thresholds
therapeutic window and motor efficacy
and also i'll touch on new candidate
biomarkers that we might
use to simplify and guide us
in post-operative programming with
both directional and potentially closed
loop
systems finally i'll discuss some
ethical considerations that relate to
crossover studies in neuromodulation
so this is the current status of our
study we're in year three
and this is a small randomized
double-blind crossover design
and we have screened 31 and implanted 24
participants
and the crossover
occurs longitudinally at over two month
intervals
uh circular dbs as we define it is
using the three contact segments in the
virtual ring together
uh as depicted on the left whereas
directional brain stimulation
is essentially anything else in this
example two contacts two and four
are active and these settings are
arrived at based on traditional
behavioral brain stimulation programming
the data in this talk arise from
the uh orange boxes in our study flow
chart
so we'll have some behavioral data from
our pre-op baseline assessments
uh we'll briefly touch on some local
field potential data that we've acquired
during dbs surgery
and uh the behavioral data is all from
what's called the monopolar survey or
the the initial session where we
activate
the device and query each contact on the
directional electrode for its
potential benefits or side effects
and we've learned that directional brain
stimulation in the sdn
has a strong effect both both on side
effect threshold
and on therapeutic window the side
effect
threshold is the stimulus amplitude at a
given
dbs contact that elicits unwanted side
effects
in the subthalamic nucleus this most
commonly is
a contralateral contraction caused by
activation of the nearby internal
capsule
of the lateral cortica spinal tract and
uh with uh if you look at a directional
lead
at the side effect threshold for each of
the contact segments and rank them from
best to worse
uh as depicted here uh on on the on the
left
in these two panels uh the red dotted
line
is the side effect threshold using the
virtual ring
and the uh uh first second and third
rank
contacts have uh
better uh intermediate and worse
side effect thresholds so directional
stimulation
on average improves the side effect
threshold
in one contact on the
among the directional contacts by about
0.5 milliamps and actually in many cases
the worst contacts worsens the side
effect threshold also by about half a
milliamp
therapeutic window is a similar idea to
the side effect threshold
this is the available range of
stimulation intensities
that provide meaningful clinic clinical
benefit and we see a similar
a similar gradient with about a half
milliamp
improvement in therapeutic window and uh
some worsening in therapeutic window
with stimulation through a contact
segment that's the
least optimal at a given row on the dbs
electrode
the uh this relationship holds both for
the dorsal
directional row and for the ventral
directional row
the data are split here to illustrate
this
we're also querying the behavioral
effects of directional versus
conventional circular stimulation so in
these panels we're looking at some
validated
motor tasks uh on the left two panels
their measures of gate they include the
comfortable walking speed
and the timed up and go test and in the
bottom right panel
uh is a nine pegboard uh
nine hole pegboard upper extremity
dexterity task
the gray boxes are both
the pre-op baseline state off
medications
and the dbs off state after implant
off medications on the day of the
monopolar survey
and then we've illustrated a
change in these motor behaviors with the
best rings
setting and with the best directional
contact settings within each individual
so each participant
is uh represents a single colored line
segment on each of the graphs
and not surprisingly dbs
is and this is unilateral dbs is
markedly beneficial uh for these
measures of gait
and for upper extremity function however
i would also highlight
in the bottom right that uh the best
directional contact
versus the best ring uh
the downward slope of most of the lines
in those line segments
uh does uh strongly suggest greater
improvement with directional stimulation
versus the best ring and this was uh
even though this is the
interim analysis uh has reached uh
statistical significance
at least with our currently enrolled
sample
somewhat similarly uh there are trends
towards greater improvement with
directional stimulation
uh in the two gate measures although um
we're still enrolling subjects
and these measures are double blind so
the participant
and the examiner both are not aware of
the patient's
stimulation status in this in this
behavioral testing
one of the issues in general with brain
stimulation
in postoperative programming is that
activating the device
is very time-consuming and tedious and
it can be a trial and error process
the particular patients in this study
spend half the day
activating the device which is quite a
bit longer than most
activation sessions in routine practice
and one of our goals
in the long term from this project is to
develop and understand
biomarkers that can give us guidance as
to how to activate these more complex
devices
this is one example of such a biomarker
that we've
more recently developed interest in this
is
uh both stimulation and recording from
a dbs lead implanted in the subthalamic
nucleus
so we stimulate in a bipolar fashion
from two contacts on the lead and then
record from the
unused contacts on the dbs lead
and i won't go into all the technical
details but we're uh
now able to remove the very very large
stimulus artifact that is related
uh to stimulation in such close
proximity to the stimulation site and
here we're delivering pairs of stimulus
pulses
so the test stimulus of interest is
delivered at time
zero and prior to the test stimulus is
another stimulus which we've
actually subtracted out or removed we
call a conditioning stimulus
and the conditioning stimulus marches in
time
towards the test stimulus and
when it begins to encroach
upon the relative refractory and the
absolute refractory period
of the elements that are being activated
by the test stimulus
you can see in the inset that this local
response
is abolished it's diminished in the
relative refractory period and then
abolished and i i would uh say that the
first response which is
extremely fast so this is 350
microseconds
after stimulus onset this is probably
the earliest recordable interaction
between the dbs pulse and
human brain tissue that can be measured
from
an extracellular recording so both that
very early response
and then a later oscillatory response
which i'll discuss
in a little more detail later they're
both abolished
uh during the absolute refractory period
we're looking at this now in the
directional brain stimulation context
so here we have a directional brain
stimulation lead with the
1331 configuration and we're delivering
stimulation
from the circular leads around the
directional contacts
so uh the recording is occur
occurring in the middle rows the dorsal
and ventral row
stimulation at the extreme ends from the
the circular electrodes
and the uh
the array of panels is in the same
uh spatial orientation as in the schema
so each panel is from one directional
lead
and in the bottom panels we see
the spontaneous resting local fill
potential
uh with a peak in what
these are continuous wavelet transforms
in the beta frequency band in this case
at around 20 hertz and
interestingly uh the directional lead
detects these potentials these
microscopic
subcortical potentials in a
spatial gradient so in the bottom left
and the bottom right
contacts there is a stronger
greater power in the beta frequency band
in another spectra as well
and in the middle bottom contact there
is a decrease uh recording of the beta
frequency
interestingly above we're looking at the
the stimulus evoked activity from the
last slide as a function of inter
stimulus interval
so you can see that actually in all of
these directional contexts there's both
an absolute and a relative refractory
period so this is a a
validation that these are uh biological
signals
and um there is
in this individual uh a very robust
correlation between the amplitude of
this later oscillatory uh activity which
has been called earner
or evoked resonant neural activity and
the beta band so
where erna is brighter the beta band is
brighter where erna
is less intense the beta band signal
is less powerful as well so this is uh
merely an example
of the some of the physiology that we're
interested in
we would like to make dbs systems more
accessible more robust
and we would like tools to tell us how
to use these technologies which are
increasingly challenging
uh uh the kinds of uh clinical
programming strategies that we have
employed with some success in the past
there are ethical considerations with a
crossover trial and neuromodulation
um one of the obvious considerations is
that
an individual participant might be
randomized to a therapy that's
ineffective
i think that there's particularly a
potential for greater risk for something
like this
if there is a biomarker
based programming strategy that is that
isn't
uh based on robust physiology or imaging
or
or if it's not linked to behavioral
observation so there are a couple of
mitigation strategies for this
um one would be uh
to allow flexibility within the
constraints of the randomization scheme
so
uh for instance in our protocol we have
circular versus directional dbs but
there is quite a bit of flexibility
within those two broadly defined
categories and patients can return for
uh stimulator adjustments if needed
another option is uh that we've taken
advantage of is to use an
active comparator and not a negative
control
we know in the case of brain stimulation
for
parkinson's disease that a negative
control would
not be tolerated well by participants
and so this decreases discomfort and
increases ability to participate in the
study
uh other strategies might be limiting
the duration of exposure
to the different conditions in
randomization
and perhaps even an early exit strategy
to terminate a random
randomization arm is truly intolerable
uh finally uh one uh sequela of the
covet 19
uh pandemic is that we currently have uh
participants who are stuck in
randomization arms
and we're awaiting the in-person
assessments that are necessary to
gather the uh the outcomes in our study
so in conclusion in these interim
analysis
we see that directional dbs improves
both the side effect thresholds and
therapeutic window
versus conventional circular brain
stimulation within
uh participants and and this is with at
least in
our acute testing during device
activation this is with comparable or
probably better motor outcomes uh
during acute stimulation although we're
still enrolling participants
there uh are a variety of candidate
biomarkers
whether stimulus about field potentials
or arresting and task-based
local field potentials they i think that
they all show promise to guide
not only directional but also adaptive
dbs strategies
but i think robust biomarker validation
is required with suitable sample size
and
other and other measures to
ensure their validity
finally we remain blinded to our primary
motor and non-motor outcomes uh
and and will not be unblinded to those
uh until uh later in the study uh
thank you very much for your attention
i'd be delighted to answer
uh any questions
and uh the i'd also uh
i'm pleased to introduce the next
speaker who is wins
dr winston chiong who is associate
professor of neurology
at university of california san
francisco
i've been asked to present on
neuroethics and in particular on points
to consider for those envisioning novel
human
applications of neurotechnology research
i'd like to begin with two broad
questions that structure the rest of my
remarks
first brain and other funding agencies
have emphasized what's been called
neuroethics integration and my presence
on this panel is one reflection of that
commitment
what does such integration really mean
though for the practice of neuroscience
i think in some ways it's a real
departure to expand conversations in
neuroscience to bring in
philosophers or social scientists or
legal scholars
as someone who's also a clinician i
think we can look to the precedent set
by the integration of bioethics and
medicine
where bioethics is now a routine part of
clinical curricula
and clinical practice but we know from
this history that interdisciplinary
exchange is not always
easy or straightforward we think that
one meeting point for this exchange is
empirical research in ethics which might
be a new concept or an unfamiliar
concept to some in attendance
we don't want neuroethics to be purely
speculative and engaged in science
fiction
we need deliberation and policy that are
rooted in evidence about stakeholders
experience
and about how neurotechnologies are
actually used
otherwise as we've already seen in some
domains of neuroethics
there is a danger of falling into what
has been called neurohype
in these remarks i'm going to take a
brief tour through some topics that
affect many research projects in human
neurotechnology
and highlight some of the empirical work
that we've been doing and that other
groups have done
to inform deliberation about these
matters i also encourage you to visit
poster ne2
where my co-pi dan dohan will present
some of our groups work in more detail
from the last year
this symposium is focused on novel human
applications of neurotechnology
one central ethical tension in many such
applications
is that in general potential surgical
and anesthetic complications would make
it too risky
to implant electrodes or device for
testing in healthy people
however in neurosurgical patients who
already have clinical indications for an
intracranial
or an interspinal procedure the marginal
added risk of
testing a new technology or conducting
experiment can be reduced
such that risk benefit ratios that would
have been unfavorable
would may instead be reasonable but we
should also be aware then that such
studies preferentially require the
recruitment
of potentially vulnerable patients with
conditions such as chronic pain
brittle parkinson's disease or drug
resistant epilepsy
requiring neurosurgical intervention
this situation has many parallels with
the ethics of clinical trials
in that present patients serve as
research participants
in studies that could provide benefits
to other people in the future
in our work we've drawn upon the broad
existing literature on ethical issues
and clinical trials
in our empirical work we've conducted
interviews with investigators from 19
nih-funded intracranial
electrophysiology studies
and have identified two broad types what
we call
opportunistic studies in which there
isn't a direct benefit to the patient
and participating
often used to explore fundamental
questions in human neuroscience
and what we call experimental trials for
novel interventions
in which there's a potential benefit but
in many cases greater marginal risk
a key issue in all human research is
informed consent
which is often made more challenging by
the complexity and unfamiliarity
unfamiliarity for many patient
participants of novel neurophysiological
techniques
how can we enhance comprehension and
ensure that research participation is
truly voluntary
in our empirical research we found a lot
of heterogeneity
in current approaches to consent and one
particularly challenging topic
is whether a clinician investigator such
as a neurosurgeon
who has clinical responsibility for the
care of a patient but is also
a pi of a lab should be the person to
obtain consent
or whether this is a role that should be
played by a research coordinator or a
research fellow
on one hand clinician investigators are
often the people on the team
who are best positioned to advise about
the clinical implications of research
participation
for an individual patient but there's
also a worry
that patients might not feel able to say
no to a doctor who's also treating them
we think it's often appropriate for
clinician investigators to obtain
consent
and regardless of which member of the
team attains consent
uh there have to be other uh safeguards
to ensure the voluntariness of research
participation
we've also been researching innovative
models and frameworks for consent
to inform best practices for human
neurophysiology studies
another key topic is the issue of
post-trial obligations to participants
this has been less a focus of our own
work but one that brain has supported
extensively
and i prefer people to work by gabe
lazaro munoz and sasuke hendrix
to some extent i think this issue
implicates broad structural issues in
research
rather than issues of individual
investigator morality
as a community we need to devise new
mechanisms for supporting research
related medical needs that participants
might have
such as technical support for patients
who wish to continue using a device
explanation for patients who would
rather not have a device
and equipment issues such as battery
replacement
prospective participants should be aware
of these potential future needs
and plans to address them as part of the
consent process
our lab has a particular interest in new
closed-loop brain stimulation devices
that both record and decode neural
activity and deliver
appropriate stimulation based on those
parameters as described by phil and
nanthia
because these devices rely on
semi-autonomous algorithms
that may operate outside the patient's
awareness or without the direct
uh involvement uh in real time of a
neurologist or a clinician
some ethicists have envisioned potential
threats to patients identity or autonomy
from their use in our work we've used
the
we focused on the neuropace rns device
which is
the device that was described by nandia
and this is the only responsive brain
stimulation device in regular clinical
use
in some ways we think of patients with
these devices as
pioneers in neurotechnology we have more
information at our poster
but we've been meeting patients
preoperatively and following them before
a year post-op
to get a better sense of their concerns
and how they're using the device and
how they're integrating the device into
their daily lives
so far issues of identity and autonomy
haven't been major concerns for these
patients
although they're still relatively early
in their clinical course
there is an unexpected finding from our
work that we're interested to share
with the broader community and get
feedback about in general
ethics is thinking about closed loop
neuromodulation focused mainly on the
stimulation or
neuromodulation limb of the loop
in our work though we found that the
ability to record store
and display electrophysiological markers
of illness
itself has a transformative influence on
many patients self-understanding
in some ways independent of the actual
treatment that's delivered
i think that this is something worth
considering for all devices that have
recording or sensing capabilities
and we have more to say about this in
our poster
rns is also interesting to us as a study
in the dissemination of a new
neurotechnology
it's one thing to develop an effective
treatment and another thing to actually
get people to use it
get them out into clinical or commercial
practice
we've also been conducting in-depth
interviews with clinicians and
neurotechnology investigators
uh if any of you our interviewees are in
the audience uh thank you so much for
your participation
one theme has been the broad
collaborations necessary to conduct and
support such
work uh really a single person or even a
single disciplines expertise
is never really enough to get these
projects going related to our findings
about neural recordings
stakeholders expressed some concerns
about how data are used
and questions about privacy and
ownership of these data
also connected to what i've said before
about neurohype we've heard about a need
to balance long-range fears
against a detailed understanding of
current limitations of these devices
zooming out it's important to think more
about the ethical culture of
neurotechnology as a field
again one feature that's very
interesting about neurotechnology
is that it requires input from many
different disciplines where each have
their own ethical traditions
in our interviews we found a clinician's
approach to ethical issues in their work
is structured by their
prior exposure to bioethics meanwhile
we found a lot more variation in
investigators engagement with
neuroethical issues
to some extent there's an element of the
division of cognitive labor
not everyone in neuroscience needs to be
a neuro-ethicist
but we have noticed that investigators
who come from training programs
or currently in research groups where
there's more integration
of neuroethics often do have greater
comfort and facility in addressing such
issues
an important question going forward is
whether there's more that we should be
doing institutionally
to foster such models for neuroethics
training and practice in neurotechnology
this is a good place for me to
transition to sharing details of our
community at ucsf
including many of the people who've done
the work that i've talked about today
also before we shut down in-person
activities due to the current pandemic
we've had a very active year full of
neuroethics meetings and discussion
which
we found very valuable and we've been
very grateful for the support of an nih
brain neuroethics grant
as well as our many neurotechnology
collaborators that have really enriched
our work
at this point we'd be very happy as a
group to open things up to live
as a group to questions things up to
live questions
but i'd like to thank this
[Music]
to him
greg there was a lot of feedback on that
um
i wonder if people could mute when
they're not talking and
i wonder if you could repeat that that
question
there was a lot of feedback on that um i
wonder if people could mute
when they're not talking and i wonder if
you could repeat
yes phil under uh the um
tab there are a few questions that were
in in in your box if you would like to
select from that list uh we probably
have time for one question
for each speaker
sure thanks greg um so one one question
uh that i had is for the rc plus
s device one of the neuro technologies
illustrated here for
for brain sensing is um how well does it
work in the setting of stimulation
artifact from therapeutic stimulation
and this is a big problem with these you
know many of the implantable
sense and stem neural interfaces um the
rc plus s does have some nice features
uh to deal with sensing during
stimulation
including stimulation blanking uh for
brief periods as well
or sensing blanking during stimulation
as well as active recharge for the
second phase of a biphasic
repolarization that being said there's
still a lot of
restrictions you can sense on the same
array as you stimulate but there are
only certain configurations
where that really really is is practical
even with our c s
great thank you
anthea if uh i think there are a couple
of questions
if you can see the tab cool down
unfortunately i don't see the questions
for some reason
i'm not sure why um
what are the primary differences in
brain signals
for example hippocampal theta in a
virtual laptop
task versus real navigation that you've
been able to
explore for really the first time
right that's a great question to really
answer that we would need to run the
same task
during a laptop scenario as well as
ambulatory and while we've done that we
we haven't quite finished analyzing the
data to be able to say
but my intuition is that you know
the um the signals perhaps would be
stronger
there may be obviously if there are
movement related signals then those
would be more dominating during the
ambulatory setting
uh that's actually a question that we're
very interested in how do
how does movement acceleration feed
vestibular
motor visual input how do all those
variables interact
during a natural you know walking
situation and we're exploring that now
so i don't really have a good answer for
that but my intuition is that the
signals
perhaps may be stronger and maybe more
dominated by movement
in certain cases and not others
although yeah to be determined
nancy while you're on i wonder if i
could ask you another question
um you've you know a big question in
in epilepsy of course is what residual
functions say does a damaged hippocampus
have you know that we need to think
about if we're going to resect it or not
have you had a chance in your work to
look at um
say navigation functions from you know
mr intact hippocampi versus maybe ones
with a little bit of hippocampal atrophy
and what are your thoughts about
that residual function of possibly
disease typicampi from your work
right yeah that's a great question to
this day we've been focusing more on
mostly on the normal
you know hippocampal region and if we do
have a patient that has atrophy
we exclude those channels for the
scientific questions where we want to
generalize to normal
to you know human hippocampal behavior
function
however as we start to you know expand
these studies and look at you know
be able to look at participants who have
atrophy or other
structural abnormalities hopefully we
can answer that question
but we haven't done so yet
thank you nanthia
uh harrison can you uh see the question
under uh directed to you yes i can say
can you hear me
yes so the question is is the advantage
of directional stimulation only for
reducing stimulation side effects
and i would say that the answer to this
is not clear
it's a very it's a very important
question
so the directional stimulation clearly
modifies
stimulation side effect thresholds
and therapeutic window in our
acute data from device activation
there there is evidence that it improved
the dexterity of uh
during a nine-hole pegboard uh dexterity
test so it improved
the time to complete the task uh and
in our interim analysis it did so in a
statistically significant manner versus
uh the ver the corresponding virtual
ring
uh the the size of the effect is
relatively small but
this was a double blind assessment so
both the participant
and the person who measured their
symptoms were not were not aware
of whether the condition was directional
versus circular
stimulation and directional versus
circular stimulation was delivered in
in random order as well so
i think that we uh this is kind of an
acute assessment when we're
kind of going through a whole bunch of
stimulation
parameters at once but i think that it
does provide some suggestive evidence
that there could be greater efficacy in
some individuals in
some settings with directional versus
circular stimulation
i guess that the real um a more
definitive answer to this will be
in our longitudinal assessments when
patients have been allocated to either
directional or circular dbs for
two-month intervals
and then we'll really uh hopefully be
able to kind of tease this out more and
the
whether it's a sustained difference uh
versus
uh relatively acute uh improvements that
we're seeing in upper extremity
function versus uh the circular dbs
the other thing i would mention is that
in the there are some encouraging trends
in the
uh gate speed and other and the timed up
and go task as well so
uh the i guess the book is still open
but uh i think there are some
interesting potential signals of
efficacy beyond the
the side effect uh the side effect
question and
these side effects are very very
important i mean it's it's important uh
in a patient with movement disorders
to i mean there are just times when you
want to turn the stimulation intensity
up
and uh so the ability to in in a in a
practical sense to be able to avoid that
uh it seems at some point uh that that
that could be useful
the flexibility
great thank you thank you
and uh winston there's a
question question for you
all right i'll take that one uh i've
been asked to comment on the ethics of
psychiatric research
and a responsibility to maintain i guess
that at a level of other brain research
so i think
uh maybe reflecting among other things
that in this session
uh there's been a lot of discussion
about applications in uh neurological
disorders
and uh less uh in psychiatric disorders
although
nancy did mention some work in mental
health but i'm looking forward to
reviewing that poster
uh i think that uh one difference right
now and i think there is a lot of active
research
um but you know one of the challenges
has been understanding the relevant
electrophysiology in the case
of many psychiatric disorders and that
remains an open and active research
question
uh we do have um uh uh
research programs uh looking at
ethical issues in closed loop devices
for
psychiatry uh uh unfortunately that's
been
uh probably the the aim of our uh nur
ethics grant that's been most effective
unfortunately by
uh the covid pandemic and our data
collection uh has
has been slowed so uh reflecting some of
the cautions i said in my presentation
about the need for evidence and
empirical work
um you know i i guess uh we can really
just
try to extrapolate from our work in
neurological disorders
and you know what we what we envision
for uh psychiatric ethics as well
um so i think that uh one thing that
will be common
uh and maybe even uh more salient in
psychiatric research is just the
challenges related to informed consent
and voluntariness
especially considering the complexity
and unfamiliarity of new interventions
as well as particular sensitivities
about the relationship between the
patient and the clinician
uh i think extrapolating from some of
our work in neurological disorders we
think that
biomarker discovery and the ability to
display and share electrophysiology with
patients
may have unexpected effects on patient
self-understanding and
to the effect that to the extent that
psychiatric disorders implicate
uh aspects of patient's sense of
identity or sense of self
uh that they may that may be a larger
issue to consider
there's been a very interesting
theoretical strain of neuroethics that's
been focused on questions of
authenticity
which is that uh when we're addressing
psychiatric disorders we may have
interventions that affect
participants motivations including their
motivation to participate in the study
or their motivation to be well and
that this may raise uh you know uh some
novel questions in the area of
psychiatry but uh here again i'd caution
that right now we don't have a lot of
evidence to
support this question but it's one that
there's a lot of conceptual motivation
for and certainly something that we and
other research groups are really
interested in
winston can i ask you a brief follow-up
you've said some intriguing things about
the
transformative nature of the sensing
piece of these neural interfaces
could you say a little more about that
do you feel that
um you know we have an obligation in
these studies to
give patients more ability to visualize
their brain data
or or share with them you know all of
our interpretations of it so they can
you know learn about themselves as we
are learning about them
yeah and i i think that that's a
challenge um so i would direct everyone
to our posters so we we do share some of
the
uh the information we have uh you know a
lot of this comes from
our uh interviews and observations of
patients
who have the the nerve based rns device
for epilepsy
uh that's a case where uh patients
describe
a lot of interesting reactions to
sort of being able to view the data and
sometimes there's a important
discrepancy
between patients own experience of
illness their experience of events that
they
may assume are epileptic in nature when
some may not be
and uh when there's what's been
described as an electric clinical
dissociation
between the patient's experience and you
know what their electrophysiology may be
um so i wouldn't say necessarily that uh
particularly in the case of researchers
where
the neural signals are different or you
know not fully characterized
um you know i don't think that there's
necessarily an obligation to share
information that we ourselves may not
understand with participants i can see
situations where that might be harmful
um i i would say more that our research
points to the importance of
attending more to the sensing limb i
think we think a lot about
the stimulation limb and at least as
neuroethysis we tend to think of the
sensing limb just in terms of how
effective that makes stimulation
and i think a really interesting enough
thing in our research has just been that
the um the ability to view their illness
experience
in this different way in this
electrophysiologically informed way
um does have some really interesting
effects on the way that patients think
about their illness experience
and also the way that other people
sometimes in the patient's
your family or immediate circle may
regard you know the reality of their
symptoms or experiences or
um you know kind of how that that
changes
their their relationship with clinician
as well so i would say more that
it's something to pay attention to and i
would imagine that in different
applications
this may have different obligations for
researchers and clinicians
great thank you winston and uh
michelle there were a number of uh
questions uh directed
uh to to your talk and
um if you can see them uh read the
question
and uh um be interested in hearing
your thoughts on them
yeah sure uh i think like i can group
at least two of them together so one
it's uh asking about the
the serious adverse event that was
reported and how was it treated
and uh there's another one that asked
about kind of that your
therapeutic margin of that percep versus
the after decide
after the charges and the seizures so
yeah the the adverse events was the
the seizure and it's only been in one
subject so that happened
at the beginning of kind of the
programming with that subject we were
testing different
frequencies in what the system calls the
video mode so
it gets a live video feed and it's doing
the sequential stimulation so as
we were increasing the frequency uh
and he was testing like covering
completely the camera
and then it started having some some
after discharges
and uh it eventually
evolved to to to a seizure it was a
partial seizure and even though it's
sort of that the system was shut off
and and he was treated so he that was
when he still had
uh eeg monitoring because it was at the
beginning of the trial
when when they're going sort of that
monitoring this is the first time we're
activating the video
and everything and it was mostly
resolved
by itself within the first couple of
minutes but he
the the the clinician the neurologist
that was
inside it still uh gave them aravind
intravenous so they have the the iv
in in line just in case of that
emergency
and that was the the only the the only
serious adverse event that that we had
in in relation to to kind of the
the margin of what the percepts and how
the i guess the functionality i guess
the question is asking about
how the theory therapeutic margins
are and uh with this after these charges
and the seizures so
the the then uh at least the
the ability of this the subjects overall
the
participants to use it and to be able to
interpret those percepts
in in video mode it it so far
hasn't like the we just had that single
adverse event and the other ones the
other
uh the other events the the the other
the adverse event reported i think
there's been only a couple that where
maybe they might have been with after
these chargers that happened once they
they had it at home
so it hasn't truly affected the usage
that the subjects are able to have
either in video mode or in the research
sessions so
it seems it's uh right now it kind of
outweighs like the
their ability to use those percepts it's
much much more beneficial so far
and if there are no
comments from the additional comments
from the panel
we'll move to
claudia uh as a
couple of questions about um
the overground ambulation and
electrical stimulation spinal cord
yes so the question is simulation
location and parameters or patterns for
walking and sanding
so really it's dependent on the
physiology of
each individual we map intensively
so we go through the different
electrodes in the array so we're using a
16 electrode array
um all individuals receive the implant
on the
on the lumbar sacral spinal cord so the
location is is very similar in all
individuals
but we do map to understand which
muscles are
turned on at the different sites of the
electrode and then what are the
differences
in in frequencies as well um and that's
very very uh in individual or
participant dependent
so in most cases uh standing is
is usually uh located a little bit more
caudal on the electrode
while walking might be a wider spread of
the electrode or even a little bit more
rostral but as we train individuals and
get
they get more used to the the
stimulation
those two things merged a little bit
the frequency usually starts a little
bit lower for sanding and the frequency
for walking it's
usually pretty stable between 30 to and
45
hertz but as again as an individual
strain
then they're they're able to stand um
for a shorter amount of uh time
at uh higher frequencies and that's
where we
try to adjust and have them learn uh
by by using the the same electro
configuration
just having to make minor adjustments
even either in amplitude or
uh frequency itself but usually
individuals are
are fairly different so the physiology
is different the injury is different
so it has to be
mapped initially to to understand kind
of the
the starting point for for each
individual
thank you thank you and
with that we're about uh
15 minutes over um but
we appreciate again the
the the excellent the excellent talks
and i assume that the talks will be
available online as well for uh
people if you've missed the portion of a
talk
um and um with
with that i'll uh uh ask if uh any of
the panel have uh final comments
uh with uh in particular dr starr
since um he really did
i i'll say most of the organizing and uh
it really uh hats off to
the whole the whole the whole panel
yeah thanks very much to the panel uh
some folks from nih
also helped organize this symposium to
make sure that it was
coordinated with other symposia and
their speakers and themes
at this so we we really appreciate all
the speakers participating and doing all
the work
of pre-recording in advance which was a
bit of an adventure but i think
i think it worked out so thank you all
very much
you